[Music]
good afternoon everyone welcome to
an afternoon session on the second day
of the conference
as part of the o grain track the organic
grain track of the growing stronger
collaborative conference
i'm erin silva i'm an associate
professor at the university of
wisconsin-madison and the state
extension specialist
in organic agricultural systems and it's
my pleasure to welcome you today
to our workshop organic row crop
management the biology of soil health
we have three outstanding speakers to
share information with you today both on
a broader
scale with respect to understanding the
biology of soil health as well as giving
some specific information on a research
project that's been
underway at the university of
wisconsin-madison for the past three
years
so we have joining us today dr matt
rourke who is a professor in the
department of soil science
and the state extension specialist in
soil fertility
we have dr teal potter who was a
postdoctoral researcher at the
university of wisconsin-madison
and is now at washington state
university
and miranda sakura who is an associate
research specialist in the department of
soil science here at the university of
wisconsin-madison
so i am going to hand it right off to
them they have a lot to share and we are
hoping to get a lot of questions from
the audience
um if you have questions please type
them in the chat
function in the sivant app we will
uh take questions throughout um
we may wait till pauses between the
speaker or address them at the end but
certainly as we go along
um ask your questions in the chat we
also have some interactive questions so
be looking out for that i will
let you know when those questions are in
the chat because we'd like to get your
opinion and your thoughts on
on some issues as well so with that i
will turn it over
to dr ruark thank you dr silva
so first off um yes i highly encourage
everyone uh
ask questions so i found that uh you
know these virtual formats are a little
different right
and it'll be a lot more fun with more
questions that we get so
uh overall uh the the title of our
presentation or organic row crop
management and the biology of soil
health
and today we're gonna cover we're gonna
have three different sections i'm gonna
talk a little bit to start on just an
overview of soil health and
just the perspective on soil health that
we know where we're coming from on it
uh miranda is going to talk about
managing for soil health and organic
production systems
so a little bit more specifics on
management and based on some
on-farm survey work we've done and then
teal is going to get into a deeper
understanding of soul microorganisms and
what they do
so the overview of of soil health
and so i would imagine
as everyone thinks about soil health you
know everyone might have a little
different take on it and so i always
like to use this slide
uh put together by my my friend steve
coleman
you know what does the soil a healthy
soil consist of right and i'm sure
everyone on this
on this uh zoo meeting here can think
about
you know several things of how they
would describe
a healthy soil right and so some of
these might be
might be have sufficient nutrients good
tilth
good workability sufficient rooting
depth
good drainage few pathogens
but um plenty of beneficial soil biota
low weed pressure no harmful toxins
to the crop and brazil uh and resilience
to degradation
now you know uh what's interesting about
this is none of this
none of these are connected to one
specific measurement per se
right so it's about healthy soil is
about what we want
and how that what the charac these
bigger characteristics are of the soil
so we all i put this together to kind of
get out
what we've done in soil health from a
soil science perspective is we have
devolved it a little bit into soil
testing
and so you're just starting with this
idea up to the left this fluffy
definition conception of soil health
we know soil health is good um but
really is it about what are the specific
things we want from the soil we had that
list before but i
you know in theory there would be a
hundred or more things we might want
from the soul right
and maybe a better way to capture that
is the idea of ecosystem services what's
that
service that soil is providing
but what we really need to do and we're
going to work over here on this side of
the world
the specific soil measurements what do
we need to measure about the soil
that does connect in some way to the
things we want from the soil
and then also in a perfect world that
these specific soil
measurements may connect to agronomic
decision making meaning if
you could quantify if you could get a
certain measurement of your soil
would can you know that you're able to
achieve higher yields
would you be able to reduce your
nutrient inputs would you be able to
reduce
your your need for
other inputs to manage pests and disease
then you have this side of the world
with crop management and all these crop
management effects that are
that are affecting these specific crop
measurements or crop management effects
that might be affecting the ecosystem
services so
you can see there it can get a little
fuzzy in here um
so i want to just make sure everyone
when we're thinking about it we do have
these things we want from the soil
but we also need to identify if soil if
the science of soil health is going to
advance we need to be able to identify
what we should be measuring and what
would be things that
we can measure in a relatively easy way
so you know we talk about ecosystem
services here's another kind of big
example of
all these other things that you know we
could list too the idea of carbon
sequestration
uh flood regulation um
foundation for human infrastructure you
know all of these different things
so it's there's so many things but it's
hard to capture like the idea of is it a
habitat for microorganisms well what
would you measure
to to know that and you might want to
measure
several things and that's the thing so
soil health is multivariate
by nature and so there's many properties
uh that can or should be measured and we
probably can't sum it up with a single
number so this is our
this is our great challenge so many of
you have probably seen these
this figure we use it all the time
there's three circles and in the middle
you know with the physical aspects of
soil the chemical properties the soil
and the biological
properties of soil and in the middle
where they all intersect that soil
health
okay so we have all these things and you
know we can kind of break it down well
chemical properties of soil these are
well studied they're easy to measure any
soil test lab can tell you you know
about
you know extractable nutrients they're
the aspect of soils that we've been
studying probably the longest
um people have been studying soil
chemistry for well over 100 years
and we know what to do with those values
if you get a you know
a ph measurement or soil nutrient levels
we can utilize that to
to you know to make lime recommendations
or nutrient recommendations
the physical aspects of soil you know
things like aggregation
compaction porosity they're well
understood
uh they're not necessarily easy to
measure because it
involves you know field evaluations but
they're often things you can see so if
you have compacted soil or you have poor
in
you know poor infiltration that's me
something that you're going to be able
to
you know sense about your soil so um
we may not you know there are things
that you can physically see and
and understand then it leaves us with
this biological measurement of soul and
that's been the big missing piece of
um soil testing for a long time it's not
i'm going to say it's not well
understood it's pretty complex
it's we can say there's certain things
that are easy to measure
but it's not we're not quite sure
exactly what to measure yet we're doing
a lot of
testing of specific measurements to kind
of bring into our soil testing world
so as we think about all of these things
um you know connecting that function to
indicator and maybe i should have that
arrow going the other way
you know if we want to manage it we need
to be able to measure it so if we want
to measure those
functions if we want to manage for those
functions we need to pick indicators
you can see this there's a laundry list
of things here uh for chemical physical
and biological
and so we've got to pair down on which
which ones we're going to use
uh the other aspect of a good soil
health indicator this is
from a paper put out a few years ago and
i thought they did an excellent job
in terms of describing you know what we
want it needs to be evidence-based so we
need to have some research on it
it needs to be sensitive to changes in
management meaning that if
you know if you're going to change a
management practice if you're going to
add a management practice if it doesn't
really it's not really affected by
management it's not going to be a good
sole authenticator
it's not going to give you a sense of uh
if you're going up or down
needs to be accurate and precise meaning
it has to have good scientific methods
behind it
it needs to be cost effective which
really means it needs to be able to be
conducted in a soil test lab and um
there's certain uh tests that are pretty
expensive
probably don't fit into our soil testing
lab
world that easily um so they're probably
going to come it's going to be limited
in its use
and then lastly it has value and that
gets the idea of can we connect it to
something um some decision making
process right it might even just be as
simple as did my yield potential go up
uh can it be connected to nutrients can
it be connected to other decision making
for other
uh you know other disease or or
pest pressures
so the part that i want to kind of kind
of circle in on here is this idea that
well
most of these measurements one of the
big things we want to do is to get at
this idea of
a specific measure of organic matter now
i'm sure a lot of you already getting
soil organic matter by loss on ignition
from soil test labs but it might be that
might not be the best
uh indicator of soil health so because
there's different
parts of the organic matter and how fast
they cycle
so we have this idea that there's this
most of this
organic matter is in this passive pool
where it doesn't cycle very fast the
turnover is decades or centuries
we have another pool that's the slow
pool that's years to decades of turnover
then we have this idea that there's this
active pool of organic matter and that
might be something we're interested in
so represents recently deposited organic
material
with that involves a lot of rapid
decomposition and cycling
of carbon and nutrients so carbon which
would be
available to the soil microorganisms and
nutrients would be available to the
organisms
and the plant so it represents you know
can represent anywhere between 10 to 15
percent of the organic matter and this
is a turnover that might happen within a
growing season
so this active pool of organic matter
can be considered an integrator of
biology and chemistry
and we're going to talk a lot today
about two specific ways we can get at
that
active pool and i'm going too fast
so there's two different ways we can get
at this active pool so the first one
is a soil incubation and this is the
idea we're going to let the microbes
tell us what's going on
so for example in this case we're going
to take soil
we're going to we're going to incubate
it at a standard temperature and
moisture
in this case we're going to measure the
carbon dioxide production over time
so meaning we're going to uh let the
microbes uh consume that active pool
produce co2 we're going to measure that
increase in co2
so that's that's one way to go but it
does take time in this case this would
be a 24-hour
uh incubation some incubations might
might be recommended for
maybe three days so it's a it does take
some time to get that
the other idea is is there a chemical
extractions can we extract that
active carbon pool in the same in the
same way we might extract soil test
phosphorus or potassium to get at some
sort of availability
and there is there's a there's a
permanganate oxidizable carbon sometimes
called poxy you might actually hear it
actually
called active carbon and it's a quick
method
and these extractions then can be easily
conducted by soil test lab so we have
two different approaches we've got the
uh we have the
incubation approach and the chemical
extraction approach
uh so there's two uh interesting papers
that have come out recently that i've
talked about some of the value of these
organ
of organic matter and organic matter
pools so the first one on the left is
this global meta-analysis on the
relationship between organic matter and
crop yields
and that connected uh organic matter
with
corn and wheat yields we're saying that
as organic matter increases
up to four percent so do corn and wheat
yield so overall there's a benefit to
increasing organic matter
and uh especially as it's tied to
production
but uh um
but it uh but it's it's still the
uh the big organic matter pool right so
it's it's that great integrator
now the the other paper that that has
come out uh
improved soil biological health
increases corn grain yield
and here we're saying roughly a 20
increase in soil health metrics which
include that
extractable carbon and the total carbon
soil together
lead to a five percent increase in yield
so all of our indicators
at this kind of growth scale here
are indicating that as we improve soil
health and and build organic matter
that's going to help our production
systems
so now now grant now this is very this
is a broad
take on this right so uh what the
research you're going to hear today is
going to
is going to get this is we've taken a
more regionalized approach to
understanding that that relationship
and then lastly then so those are the
those are the simple measurements
and then the question is is there more
value in more complex biological
measurements
and so with this is this is one of the
big things we're studying on a lot
of of our research is well there are
these more sophisticated measurements we
can do
such as soul amplicon sequencing that
can tell us which
bacteria and fungi are present we can do
soil metagenomics
so it gets at what the bacteria and
fungi are capable of doing
uh we can also do soil meta uh
transcript dot mix uh that gets to what
the bacteria and fungi are
actively doing now uh and so
you might hear some of these terms a
little bit later so we have the idea of
like what are these simple measurements
are they providing value
and then do we is there something else
we can learn by having these more
biological uh more complex biological
measurements taken
and what can we learn from them so as we
kind of have more discussions today so
soil health
um is a young emerging field that needs
refinement
uh our angle that it needs soil type and
region specific recommendations and
that's hopefully what we're
we're gonna demonstrate today uh to a
certain extent
uh it might need crop specific
recommendations that might be
um you know do grain crops and vegetable
crops may differ
uh in terms of of how they're responding
to soil health
certainly we do recommend it should be
evaluated over time you know i haven't
talked about the idea of
soil health as a metric you know is it
something to see where you're going are
you increasing maintaining or decreasing
it needs to be connected to all s
aspects
of uh of i should say output which is
yield and quality so that does tie to
vegetable and fruit production
as well so um
with that uh we do have a question um
that would like to pose to the group
uh before uh miranda starts to talk and
the question is if you had funds
is i make sure this is the right one if
anyone's okay if you have funds to
implement or adjust one management
practice to improve soil health
what management practices would you
prioritize and
uh dr silva is going to put that up in
the chat and um
and we encourage you you all to answer
yeah i think i put it in this
i think i put it in the live q a so you
can see
it and what we'd like you to do and
we're hoping to use the upvote function
but i'm not sure if that's going to work
um ideally if we were live teal does an
awesome job doing live polls as part of
the presentation
but if if you can um put one of these
letters in
as a question so we can get a sense of
where
you might want to prioritize that would
be awesome kind of a fun way to
to see um what people are thinking um so
we'll give that a shot
trying some novel things with the
q a function
while we're waiting for that for a
minute we do have one other question
in the chat do you want to look at that
right now matt
uh the one that aaron just posted that
says uh
with respect to biological testing
indicators could you not start with
doing biomass assessments of the soil at
the root zone
for major member components of the soil
food web for example
uh f to b ratios decomposers
symbionts nutrients cyclers etc
so yeah so the answer is yes the problem
is
i would put those in the category of
more complex measurements
um to get that information and these are
becoming i mean these are routine
uh i mean these are analyses that we can
do you know pretty easily in an academic
setting
um but our more expensive tests uh
for um for soil test labs to
implement as of now as of now um so
the the big the big struggle we have in
soil health and soil health testing is
that idea between
uh cost and benefits so there are places
where you could probably get this
information
but it's going to be certainly a lot
pricier it is not these aren't rapid
tests that can be incorporated uh easily
necessarily into sole test labs so
and i think you're going to be we're
going to see some more discussion on
those types of measurements later on
oh people are putting in answers all
over the board which is so interesting
as well as options
under clarifying the other of grazing
and
improving soil texture so this is
awesome i love the interaction here
so so with that and and i and i hope uh
i think uh
this is gonna be great hopefully we can
keep that um all the comments coming in
so that i'm gonna turn it over to uh to
miranda socorro
all right thanks matt um so matt gave us
a place to start in terms of
thinking about what soil health is and
how do we measure it and make sense of
it right
we also heard from y'all about what
management you'd prioritize for soil
health and apparently our list didn't
encompass it all and of course it didn't
um but now we're going to delve into how
to answer the questions that we want to
know about biological self how are we
how are you doing that
so we want to know things like how do we
design soil health assessments
that give us useful information to
make farm management decisions and what
management decisions should we make
that would give us desired biological
functions
well i hate to break it to y'all but
there isn't a single approach that gives
us it all
as matt said it's pretty complicated um
but researchers they're taking multiple
approaches to understand what's the most
important factors for biological soil
health
so whether that is related to the
cropping system its diversity
um what kind of management is being
utilized on the farm by the farmers
and what's going on with the soil and
its inhabitants
so each approach has its own strengths
and weaknesses but we'll look at three
research projects
that are happening in wisconsin as case
studies and some lessons learned
all right so the three research
approaches we will look at today cover a
huge range
in terms of how realistically they
represent what would happen on a farm
the closest we can get to reality is the
field survey approach
so this utilizes fields on working farms
compared to
fields on agricultural research stations
so there's no experimental treatments or
prescribed management practices
implemented it is more so a survey of
management that is already happening on
the farm
so with that management that's happening
we can explore
and try to explain differences in soil
health measurements by the different
management practices happening
at the other end of the spectrum we have
greenhouse experiments
so greenhouses are really controlled
settings
we can make sure that the crop growing
conditions are optimal or at least not
limiting so that we can look at
microbial community effects
and processes that are they are
performing and how that affects the
crops themselves
also in these greenhouse experiments we
can really limit external factors so
that we can focus on specific questions
to
things like microbial community
composition and the functions that they
perform
so in the middle of these two are field
scale and plot scale
experimental trials that occur on
agricultural research stations
so these kinds of trials determine the
effect of specific management practices
or cropping systems
on whatever we're interested in in this
case biological soil health
so on one side we have the farm fields
which represent
the most realistic situation but it's
really
complicated there's a lot of factors and
variation involved
because there's so much different
management and different soils on
different fields
but this makes them really interesting
to understand and identify trends and
what's happening on these farms
but as i said they're complex there's a
lot of noise to sift through
because of those differences so it's
hard to pinpoint
what are the key things happening
for those kinds of studies you need a
lot of fields to participate so that we
can kind of mitigate that effect
but in the controlled greenhouse
experiments you get rid of a lot of that
noise to answer those specific questions
but then we are limited to the kinds of
questions that we can ask
so it's a smaller subset
all right so first we're going to look
at a field survey
so remember field surveys utilize the
differences in management
already happening on working farms
but also has the field differences and
soil characteristics
as important characters factors to
identify
so in this case we are interested in
important factors for biological soil
health
field surveys don't necessarily look at
change over time
but they are more so a survey of what is
contributing
to differences between fields and what
is
making those contributions
so an example of this is a sare funded
project in the southwest driftless area
of wisconsin
that is down here in this southwest
corner of wisconsin
um worked with 16 organic grain and
dairy farms
so um we worked with them to evaluate
how differences in soil characteristics
things like texture and ph as well as
management affect biological soil health
so we visited the farms in 2018 and 2019
to take soil samples at 124 fields
they were taken in spring before the
planting of the next cash crop
each field was following a corn year so
that we controlled for what the previous
crop was
trying to mitigate some of that noise
all right so in the upper right you see
that there's a an icon that indicates
we're talking about field surveys
um teo will also be presenting results
on the field survey so that's a way to
let you all know
all right so for the study we obtained a
detailed history from the farmers of the
previous five years of management
so that's related to the cropping
sequence and its diversity
as well as the tillage management
tillage management and manure management
utilized on the fields we also got some
more long-term information
such as how long have the fields been
organic and what was their previous use
to organic
[Music]
to obtain data on field soil
characteristics we use the publicly
available
soil data from nrcs's web soil survey
so you might have seen something like
this before if you try to utilize nrcs's
tool to look at your own soil
it's an online platform with
location-based data
that's from soil mapping of the united
states the information obtained from
here is primarily soil factors that are
outside of the farmer's control
like soil texture and its classification
something we want to know is what soil
characteristics are the most influential
on biological soil health
so that soil health assessments when you
send in a sample
to get soil health testing those
assessments take into account the soil
differences
that are outside of the farmer's control
so we can rate them among peers
you can get more accurate assessments
because not all soils have the same
capacity for soil health
and specifically for certain functions
so we need to include these differences
when we rate how well a field is doing
so is if like a is a field um
median or less or less than a third of
its potential or is it meeting greater
than two-thirds of its potential
you know those are some things we want
to know
all right so matt gave a little intro
into some of the indicators that we
measure but
we're going to talk about four specific
ones so one of those is
permanent oxidizable carbon or epoxy
so this one is related to carbon as matt
was saying and it measures the readily
available
fraction of soil carbon that microbes
can use as an energy source
basically it represents how much food do
microbes have easy access to to perform
their key soil functions
how much resource do they have
the other method matt was talking about
is mineralizable carbon
so this is a measure of that co2 release
by microbes as a result of their
activity
so just like how we release co2 when
we're performing functions we're going
for a walk we're going for a run
we release different amounts of co2 the
harder we work
all right we also measured autoclave
citrate extractable protein
so this is soil protein and that's the
largest nitrogen fraction
of soil organic matter in the soil and
that fraction the
microbes they can convert that via
decomposition
to plant available forms of nitrogen so
represents bioavailable nitrogen that
might be crop available
[Music]
while another measure we use is
potentially mineralizable nitrogen
so this measures the rate by which
microbes convert
that organic form of nitrogen to plant
available forms so also getting that
bioavailable nitrogen but
asking more so how fast are microbes
able to turn over that nitrogen
so this gives us some informations in
terms of some biological soil fertility
as well as carbon dynamics happening as
well how are we moving towards
organic matter
all right um we're now going to look at
a snapshot of the management that's
happening on these fields
so in this management is only what was
happening
in the previous five years before the
samples were taken
so to a lot of the farmers for utilizing
management practices that aim at
preventing soil erosion
limiting soil disturbance and overall
improving soil health
[Music]
and you know it might be performing more
multiple functions like that like
providing nitrogen
so 79 of the fields had a perennial crop
within the last five years and that was
primarily alfalfa
so both providing perennial cover and
nitrogen biologically
seventy-six percent of fields had prone
to legume cover and twenty percent had
annual legume cover
also you might notice here that um
the fields were pretty split in their
cover crop use so
a little over 50 of the fields had
covered a winter cover crop
less than 20 of the fields utilize
minimum tillage
over the five-year period which we
defined as a disc implement or
shallower tillage implement and you also
see that about 20
of fields had at least one year of
no-till
um within the five years
and most of the fields applied manure so
that was one of the things that was
pretty consistent
between fields but overall you see that
there's a lot of different management
practices happening on the skills
but does this lead to measurable soil
health differences does it tell us
something about management
we're going to look at a subset of
management practice data to tell the
overall story
[Music]
so over the five year period the number
of years of legume cover
perennial cover or a winter cover crop
did not produce a measurable effect
on these four biological measurements
that we measured
the number of manure applications didn't
have an effect either
but what about some other practices
it did i identify a few management
practices but
all of the effects were small so the
biggest relationship identified
was with crop diversity so as crop
diversity
increased epoxy pmn and ace
increased however at most
it explained less than six percent of
the differences
um in soil health measurements between
fields
um and that is seen by these r squared
values um you can measure like
take these r squared values times them
by a hundred and that basically tells
you the percent
that um the number of different crops is
able to explain
in these proxy values
so what you're seeing is that less than
six percent
of epoxy differences in proxy
is explained by crop traversing so
there's this leftover
94 percent that is from other factors
such as soil characteristics and
management
you can also see that how long a field
has been certified organic
had small effects so hoxie as
um as the length that they've been
certified organic increased epoxy
increased and ace increased
but it was very small so uh these small
effects you know they're they're a bit
disheartening um
but let's look at this a little bit more
in detail
so we're going to focus in on that
duration of organic management piece to
kind of think on us more so in the study
farms they ranged from being in
transition to organic
to having over 27 years of organic
management
so that's quite a long range even with
this long range
less than four percent of differences in
soil health values
this case epoxy and ace were explained
by how long they've been organic
so there's a leftover 96 percent
again that is explained more so by
other factors such as soil
characteristics and other management
practices that are happening on the farm
farms are really complex systems and
they're managed differently for a number
of reasons
so there is more variation captured on
working fields then it recommended
experimental trials
although i don't think you know there's
still an important message here
right the important message is that
management practices
and soil characteristics are more
critical than time
there's some young fields that have
really
high biological soil health and there's
some older fields with low
biological soil health so understanding
which management practices contributed
the most
to the high soil health values is really
critical into
improving biological soil health
to make things a little bit more
complicated something we should remember
is that not all soils have the same soil
health potential
regardless of management this is due to
soil properties that are outside of the
farmer's control
for example ball saws soils formed under
historical prairie cover have higher
soil organic matter than several other
common wisconsin soils
used for agricultural production and
this is due to the long-term
contributions of that prairie's root
system
turning over those roots and leaving
behind so
organic matter so soil health
assessments need to account for these
differences in soil
potential to properly rate current field
soil health values
using the publicly available soil data
we found that the u.s soil
classification system was useful for
explaining differences in soil health
values
this is important as we can separate
soils into different groups
by their classification to rate their
soil health according to their true
potential
so on the screen is a map of the
classifications represented in the study
we're talking about in the driftless
region
so of the 124 fields in the study
the soils there's about i think five
soil classifications
represented in the study and that makes
up a majority
of the acreage in the driftless area
um so basically we have a study with
really well represented soils of the
driftless region
so that suggests that we can use these
soil classifications for benchmarking
soil health in this region
okay so that was talking about
on-farm studies now we're going to
transition to experimental plot trials
with a focus on long-term research
trials
so this utilizes field scale and plot
scale experiments with replicated plots
so repeated areas with the same
management
and it looks at the effect of management
over time
[Music]
in arlington wisconsin there's a
long-term research trial known as the
wisconsin
integrated cropping systems trial or
wixed
and it was established in 1989 so
there's over 31 years of data
of how this management has affected the
soil that's there in
other qualities so this trial
specifically its purpose is to evaluate
the productivity
profitability and environmental impact
of organic and conventional agricultural
practices
in the upper midwest
the plots they're about three quarters
of an acre size so they're trying to
get near um to that field scale size
to better represent the reality of what
would happen on a farm
now going into what the cropping systems
are there are six common cropping
systems
of the upper midwest chosen to look at
their long-term effects so the first
three in the top row
we have cash grain systems so this is
continuous corn
a corn soybean rotation with minimum
tillage
and a organic cash grain system which
has corn soybeans to wheat and red
clover
so the bottom three represent dairy
forage systems
so we have a conventional system that
goes from corn to three years of alfalfa
our organic forage system that goes from
corn to
an oats nursing crop with alfalfa and
one more year of alfalfa
and then the last one is a highly
managed rotationally grazed pasture
so the catchphrase systems and dairy
forged systems
they differ in their inclusion of
perennials so with dairy forage systems
there's more perennials represented
the inclusion of perennials also
inherently reduces disturbance so
these broad categories differ in these
two ways
you can also see that especially for the
cash grain systems that there's a
gradient in crop diversity
so we're able to ask questions about
that as well
for both the cash grain and the dairy
forge systems there's an organic system
represented
so we're able to ask questions about
organic and conventional management
so here's a snapshot looking at year 27
of this project so in the 27th year
we have pmn mineralizable carbon epoxy
measured these biological soil health
indicators
and what was found out is that the dairy
forage systems had the highest
biological soil health values
and primarily the rotationally grazed
pasture had the highest
out of all of these cropping systems so
the rotationally grazed pasture
is a much different system than the
others as it has continuous living cover
with no disturbance the living mat
protects the soil
and the roots are constantly sloughing
off
and that material that root is fueling
the soil system
um so the other cropping systems that
had higher biological health the
dairy forage systems they had more
perennial cover
so also less disturbance and more living
roots presented represented
yeah so specifically these derivative
foreign systems they had more of that
active carbon pool that carbon source of
few
food for microbes they had higher
microbial activity and they had a higher
rate of converting
that organic nitrogen to plant available
forms
so the organic systems did not
have better biological soil health than
the
conventional systems within those bins
of cash grain
and dairy forage um
yeah but the experimental trial was able
to
capture this effect of perennial cover
which wasn't previously found in the
on-farm study
so that these experimental trials are
able to get rid of some of that noise
that we see on farm studies
to like capture more management
practices
and that's something we saw here
miranda it looks like there was one
question about whether you have any
plots in the green bay or fox river
valley areas
this study did not it was specifically
looking in the driftless area to kind of
so we have the effect of different soil
characteristics to like look at that
but also we didn't want to have super
different soils
so we kind of limited that way but i
know that maybe matt can talk about this
later that there's been a wider
study all over wisconsin and somewhat in
minnesota
but that's mostly focused on
conventional systems
so if that's of interest we can talk
about that
maybe later all right there's a couple
other
questions coming in
if there can be more information about
the
specific practices on farms specifically
if
we can give the names maybe we can't
give the names but maybe at least
specific practices particularly if
there's any doing
rotational grazing i think as these were
i think
all pretty much not all but most organic
dairy farms that many of them would have
had rotational grazing
as part of their management
yeah that's right so a lot of them are
organic dairy
so they did have pastures but we didn't
sample from them we were more focused on
these organic row crop systems and how
those specific fields were rotating
but there was a field or there's
multiple fields that
was transitioned from a conventional
pasture system
to an organic grain system and those
fields
um it's been like 10 years since they
were that conventional pasture system
but they had higher biological soil
health values just because they were
a pasture at least that's my
interpretation of it it wasn't many
fields but
um yeah
thanks miranda and there's another
question and and matt i don't know if
you want to
chime in on this one too from other
studies that you have done
with um at wixed but there's a
clarifying question as to the date the
wix data that the chemicals that were
applied in the conventional forage
system
versus the organic didn't seem to be
impacting soil health in a negative way
um in in terms of the
indicators that we've measured right so
in terms of the
of the thing so you know what
the so i guess that that is correct so
we didn't see a difference in in our
the conventional system there is one
year of corn with three years of alfalfa
versus uh the organic system is one year
of corn with
uh two years of alfalfa so it's a longer
set of
perennialization um
those sort of factors kind of work out
the biggest differences tended to be
from cropping system right so going from
the grain cropping systems to those
cropping systems
so the nuance of it uh we couldn't we
couldn't pull out so
um it seemed to be the broader carbon
input
and soil disturbance and manure input
effects that would have had the biggest
benefit in terms of the
the simple biological health indicators
that make sense and teal mentioned that
she's gonna
talk a little bit about that too
um so another question related to
wix the forage systems appear to give
better soil health numbers but how
significant are those differences
how significant uh it
right what is you know i'm sorry what is
significant mean right so is it mean
that it's
um static they were statistically
significant
do they matter you know what do they
connect to um
in terms of any of these ecosystem
services
i don't know i don't know um those sort
of
that sort of stuff we don't have that
quite connected
um
that's not a very satisfying answer i
know the uh what
the i know it just gets into such a a
goofy little trick of
this is you know one location and it's
very soil specific right if you're
already working on a nice
deep malasal soil that you kind of beat
the heck out of
you know maybe it's just these broader
ships and these subtle ships don't
really
don't really matter but even the even
our biological health and our
uh grain systems was still probably
pretty good um
so what does it connect to um
i don't uh i don't have a good answer
for that i'm sorry
that relates to another question matt
that's kind of along those same lines
what is the soil type on the arlington
farm and do you think the results would
have been the same
comparatively on the boone sand of the
person asking the question
so the what our one of our goals
you know one of miranda's goals and one
of our goals for
other soil health projects is to create
these baseline measurements because
you know obviously as miranda showed
there's so much inherent the inherent
properties of soil
do have a syllabus controlling factor on
on your your baseline soil health
measurement so it really
uh i would pare it down to even like
miranda's work is
some of the best on the subject because
it's so geographically and so
soil um specific focused
um yes in general
sandy soils will have lower soil health
values than uh
you know silt loam prairie derived soils
so as we think about how are we
splitting these out in terms of what a
baseline what's an expected value and
then within
each soil texture uh soil classification
system how much can you influence it
based on
based on measurement and then at the end
of the day
what does it connect to and so we have
all of these things that you know i
talked about up front that we're still
we are still scratching the surface on
it so right now we have a pretty good
handle on the the relative importance of
inherent properties versus management
properties in which direction these
management properties
or the management might affect soil
health um and generally speaking it fits
it fits the general narrative more
carbon inputs less soil disturbance
um although not all those um necessarily
or
um were found significant in miranda's
work
but then the trick is what does it mean
what does it mean for your cropping
system to
to do this and is that something you'd
want to manage for or are you just
do you just want to manage because
reducing tillage means reducing
you know fuel costs and reduces and we
know it reduces
uh you know sold disturbance and
improves the soil so
uh this is i know it becomes a bit of a
circular argument but that's really kind
of where we're at
we haven't fully connected all of these
these measurements the soil health
measurements
to uh some sort of benefit where you
talk about those
if you want if it's significance is a
significant difference for what
and ideally be in my mind one of the big
ones would be for plant health and plant
production
there's a couple questions related to
soil testing
both you know how useful
the usual soil tests are for the average
organic farmer that maybe they're
they're not very helpful
give a specific recommendation for soil
tests
and how often an average organic
rotation with alfalfa corn soy and
clover
should soil test and specific
not only in terms of what tests but are
there
what are the best soil test labs in
michigan was specifically
recommended so what's the ideal panel of
indicators what should people test for
um how often should they test what left
should they send to maybe we should have
you give another talk matt specifically
on on
test labs i mean i would always
recommend you know i was just like a
routine test test your nutrient levels
you know i think testing over time i
think is really where the real value is
for a lot of
uh a lot of this so having you know
in general we recommend sampling every
four years but you know sampling every
other year might be good the more data
you can build
and then graph that across time which
direction are you going with your
nutrient levels in your soil with your
organic matter
and um any soil biological tests so a
lot of these soil biological tests are
being incorporated into different soil
test labs so you might be able to find
some test labs that are doing something
i kind of like it especially if you're
just sort of looking at stuff over time
again you know i say we don't know
exactly what to do with that numbers
there's some
labs that might want to connect it to
nutrient availability
i don't know i i don't know i don't have
any data to
support that but i do like the idea of
using that to monitor it over time
um and i think sometimes in today's
world i really honestly think with all
these
climate extremes we're facing i think
maintaining soil health is still as big
of a win as increasing soil health
so everything anything we can do to to
not further be reducing soil health
i think that's this a win for us so if
you can be if you can increase that's
great but
even to know you are maintaining soil
health uh with your
with your cropping system and management
practices is a good thing to know
well there's some more questions but i
think that some of these might relate to
what teal's going to talk about
so what i think i'll do is hold off on
the questions please keep
typing in questions though these are
great questions um but i think i'm gonna
um hold off have teal present her
information because again i think it
will inform some of these other
questions and then we can go back to the
q a from there
sounds good so can you see my screen
are we good
all right um so i'm teal i have been
working on some of the
same data sets as miranda so you'll see
those icons in the corner of my slides
as well
but i'm going to talk a little bit more
about the biological
component of soil health
and getting into the details of what we
we are trying to answer some of these
questions of
how does this living component of the
soil
connect to these soil health indicators
that we
know are sensitive to management know
have you know pretty inexpensive ways to
measure
but we still have a lot to do like matt
was saying to connect this
in and find out what is the useful
information that we need
moving forward
so you know we do
microbes are important they are the ones
processing
decomposing the organic matter in the
soil to make it available for plants
and also storing it in carbon so we do
want to use our microbes
to um and make their function
stronger so for reasons like disease
pressure
reducing chemical inputs helping get
maximum yields in our fields and
it is pretty complicated as i know
you've heard but i'm going to show you
some of my research to illustrate this
so and there are microbes and other
biota that
can contribute to a lot of different
functions in the soil
so in contributing to soil health
disease suppression plant drought
resistance
plant nutrient acquisition carbon
sequestration
nutrient mineralization so making those
carbon and nitrogen
phosphorus available to the plants and
water use
these are some of the functions we're
talking about when we're thinking about
the microbial component
and a lot of what you may hear of a lot
of the products
that you see that are microbial focus
are focused on microbes that have
specific
relationships with the plants
so you've probably heard about
mycorrhizal fungi
which trade plants plant roots carb
they trade nitrogen phosphorus
water for carbon sapr
troves are taking nutrients
from plants rhizobia these are bacteria
that fix nitrogen for plants some plants
endophytes are microbes there's a bunch
of microbes that live in
plant tissues and then pathogens you
know we got to remember that pathogens
are
microbes too they're part of this
microbial
microbiome in your soils they're fungi
and bacteria so we're thinking
i'm thinking about all these symbionts
that have specific relationships with
plants
um but then there's a lot that's going
on
for mediating how they mediate plant
responses
and so for an example we think of
mycorrhizae
mycorrhizal fungi
as this great mutualist so plants
benefiting
microbes are benefiting they're trading
nutrients but
in certain conditions if the plant
doesn't need those nutrients
say phosphorus the microbe is in the
microbes are still attached
they can steal carbon from the plant so
we do need to understand
this microbiome better because it's not
as simple as
mycorrhizae are good for your plants
right they can
start stealing your plants carbon
and what i'm most interested in is
thinking about this whole context most
of these microbes are not symbionts
they are free living microbes that are
in the soil they might
be associated with plant roots in that
they're
they're getting nutrients that those
plant roots are secreting into the soil
but they might not be pathogens or
mutualists
and they are competing with plants and
completing with pathogens
for nutrients in the soil so
taking the big picture view is important
but it makes it really complicated when
we know that there's
you know more than 10 000 species in a
single teaspoon of soil
so i'll show you how we're getting at
some of this complexity and trying to
distill it down
and you know we do know that there is
lots of evidence that farming practices
can impact soil biology so
this is important to know there's a lot
of studies
tons of studies that have shown this but
it's not always
and the responses vary by soil type and
climate
and the responses are not always huge
not even usually huge
so there's a lot of reasons to focus on
a small area
but it is important to know in a
specific area whether management
practices do have consistent effects on
biology
within a region before we ask does it
matter
right go to that next step
and so going to our
our field survey you can see the icon in
the corner that miranda talked about
we asked how does organic farming change
soils over time
and
to do this we use these fields that had
been under organic management for
different lengths of time
and we measured does this change soil
health indicators
you know what i'm interested in taking
this a step further is can we measure
differences
in the biological community the living
communities
and we did this with um all these fields
from across all these farms and because
there's a lot of noise
um differences among farms and soil
types
um we did need a lot of samples
so the question here is you know no
one's done this before just seeing
whether organic farming has a consistent
effect
on microbes before we can ask you know
what are they doing is it helping us and
we don't know if that's a consistent
increase they just keep going up or if
it plateaus after a certain number of
years
or maybe it goes up and goes down we
need to explore this
and so this is what we did
on 124 field samples to hopefully see
some pattern among the noise
and here's the data right here so also
with biology
consistent with some of the measurements
or the measurements that miranda told
you about
we just see no pattern
and so there could be high fungal
species for
as one example we measured biomass we
measured
this for bacteria as well but there's a
lot
going on here right so there was
probably tillage in the past history and
there's tillage still happening on
organic farms
the manure inputs are variable among the
farms
your rotations a lot of these farms are
doing similar crop rotations
but different sequences um
and so what to me this tells me one
thing that's definitely different is
whatever pesticides or whatever
non-organic certified inputs
those do not seem to have a consistent
effect either those are breaking down
pretty rapidly and we're not detecting
that early on
or you know there's a lot of microbes
out there that's what i'm always
thinking about
so there's a lot more that is being
influenced at the field scale than
specific certified organic management
practices
so this is interesting and also brings
to the point that
these long-term field studies are really
helpful to
seeing like within a region and very
precise
consistent management can we see effects
so we can understand when those
when those might be important and what
is driving it
interestingly this paper just came out
this year that shows
inconsistent effects of agriculture
practices on soil fungi
fungal communities across 12 european
long-term experiments
and a lot of these have been going for
over a hundred years
so this is in belgium uk hungary
and denmark and you can see that just on
these outer
venn diagram loops there's pretty high
highly different numbers in the uk they
had 124 fungal species
in hungary they had 878 right so
determining whether that matters
probably is something you'd want to
focus on
within your cropping system and thinking
about how it changes over time
because we see this variability
so with that i'm going to share a little
bit what i found from the long term
trial that miranda also talked about
looking at the biological components
from that system the wisconsin
integrated cropping system trial
and we measured it took samples from
five
of the six cropping systems that
are represented of the region
and we did also find
a lot of miranda's work showed that
there's differences in poxc
and a lot of these indicators and
we also found that among these cropping
systems there were significant
differences
in the continuous corn especially
between continuous corn the most the two
extremes continuous corn and pasture
we also saw this for biomass so we
didn't see it for bacteria that was
significant differences but for biomass
we saw the same pattern for fungi and
bacteria
lowest biomass microbial biomass and
continuous corn similar
for the organic cash grain system
and quite a bit higher but we had some
questions for matt early on that
is really important to address you know
what
what do these measure what do these
differences mean how much change is
meaningful
so comparing our pasture um
versus corn we can ask well
what can 68 additional species do for us
right and that is too broad a question
for a scientist to do anything with we
have to focus in a little bit so maybe
we could ask
does 68 additional species increase
organic matter decomposition
and another thing to note here is we're
talking about you know 68 species that's
i don't know
how to think about that so i don't know
if you can think about that
in a in a useful way but we are talking
about 68 species
in a quarter of a gram of soil right
it's
it's very small scale what we're able to
measure
in the lab so these are super diverse
systems
i just wanted to make that note because
that's what we're talking about
um so to answer this question
um ecologists think that about this two
different ways
how what does increased species
diversity
mean what could it mean functionally
well
one of the predominant ways in which we
think about that is more species
means more types of microbial
metabolisms
oops which means more
efficient decomposition you have
microbes that are decomposers
and i had a question about that there
are so many different types of
decomposers there's decomposers that
focus on lignin
on cellulose on proteins on tons of
different things
so if you have more different types of
metabolisms
you might get corn stalks
turned into you know salvaging that
little bit of nitrogen in them
or at least feeding the microbes more
efficiently
the other main hypothesis
is that more species if you have more
species
you're in a huge pool of species you're
more likely to have a few
that are really good at whatever you
want to decompose
or whatever your function is so along
with the other soil health indicators
there's this general thinking that more
is better
and but here for microbes here's the
thinking behind it
and these are things that we can test
and i'll show you a little bit
but i'm going to briefly bring this back
to biomass
so in this case the question might be
you know does this difference matter
and probably most of you are not you
know you want to
grow cash crops so maybe your question
is not
how much better is it if i don't tell at
all and i just have pasture your
question might be
if i change my practices a little bit
and i want to
grow corn organically does 19
millimoles more of biomass
or 38 millimoles of microbial cells what
can that do for us
to focus that in maybe your question
might be does a difference in six
millimoles matter for long-term
carbon storage well interestingly
the hypothesis here is that more biomass
actually does contribute more stable
carbon
for long-term carbon storage and this is
something
i didn't appreciate much until recently
but there is a lot of great science
happening
recently that has been showing that a
huge
contributor to stable carbon in soils is
actually
the cell walls of micro bodies
so dead more microbes means more dead
microbes
that are actually recalcitrant forms of
carbon in the soil that don't break down
easily
so i think that's pretty interesting
that we're finding that
they break down less quickly than most
plant
plant tissues so
i do want to follow up with this you
know i asked this question
is a increase better can we detect a
difference in something we might be
interested in
so we actually did this study in the
greenhouse which is pretty rare
but i'm going to tell you a little bit
about that study now
so for this study we're interested in
you know how does soil management affect
soil microbes and then
bringing that back to something we're
interested in like plant yields
crop yields so we went back to some of
the fields that we
surveyed in the field survey
study and collected soils from them
and we use them in a greenhouse
experiment
and this can allow us to ask this more
specific question right
because we can get all these soil
microbes from different places in a
controlled setting
and test their function
so the question here was do soil micro
microbial communities from different
farms
influence crop growth differently
and we really are interested in whether
they affect
crop growth differently but to really
see this we wanted to give the microbes
a functional test
this might not be enough to detect
anything so what we do
we did is we give them different forms
of organic forms of nitrogen and urea
and see if the microbes can decompose
these organic
sources of nitrogen differently so we
added the same amount of nitrogen
even those different amounts of biomass
and we wouldn't expect
to see differences in urea because
well the microbes don't need to
decompose that at all
that is readily available for plants to
take up but these other ones we thought
we might see some differences
so here i'm going to share a quick video
this is a 40 second video on
this the methods on this greenhouse
setup
so this is showing we went out to the
fields collected soils
we sterilized soil for the background
soil in the pots from a local soil
added that to the back of the pots the
95 of the volume
added live soil as five percent of the
pots
so from the different farms and then on
top of that we added an
equal amount of nitrogen in the forms of
urea manure
clover and sorghum sudan grass and then
we had the microbes decompose that
and then the corn was at a v4 stage we
harvested the experiment and dried the
plants
and weighed the plants so that was
a very quick method section there and as
we
expected we didn't see that different
communities microbial communities from
different farms we didn't see
any effect on plant growth on corn or
rye growth
in the urea addition pots
we interesting we also did not see any
differences among
farms for clover and manure which had a
similar carbon to nitrogen ratio
but we did see that it mattered which
microbes some microbial communities
allowed for more corn and rye growth
and so how we're thinking about that
is that you actually might need more
complex
or more diverse microbial communities
to efficiently break down the lignin
the cellulose this
tougher form of nitrogen
to make that available to the plants and
some communities might do that better
perhaps that is related to management
and what those fields were receiving
recently
i haven't looked at that to see if we
can detect that
so wrapping it up here
we can say that soil biology does matter
these processes are done by
soil microbes but biology is persistent
if you're in the midwest you have a ton
of microbes in your soil so we're really
interested in
detecting small changes and thinking
about
small changes i think that's my personal
perspective
i do think that understanding biology
better may be able to
help us understand soil health
indicators better
but i think a take home i would
like to say is that we're not at a point
where we can give specific advice on how
to manage your microbial community to
get these benefits
but the best practices we have for soil
health
are likely to help your microbes so if
you're
having your fields covered more
doing minimal tillage as possible
doing things to build so organic
material in your fields those are things
that
feed the microbial communities right so
more diversity and more biomass on your
fields
is going to get you more microbes and
more diverse microbes
so i think that's kind of where we're at
happy to answer some
questions thanks teo
um and related to that last point
um there was a question
um is is there either through your work
or through other work that you know an
inverse correlation between the amount
of tillage and the amount of fungi
um hearing that tillage is bad for
fungal communities and may be related to
that
and again that this may not be measured
in this study but maybe from other
literature if you do have tillage how
fast
quickly do those fungal communities
recover
how bad is tillage that is a great
question
um i'm actually starting some new work
in a new postdoc position that's going
to be tilling up some
fields that haven't been tilled in 10
years to see if we can
measure that on a fine finer scale
there's been some work on it
and in general the thinking among the
science we do have
is that um you know tillage does
decrease
fungal biomass um it has
maybe slight negative effects on
diversity but there is
enough variation among the studies that
um
it's it's not super consistent
um how fast it happens so i do
that is a great question on recovery
that's exactly what we're going to test
and do these
fine scale measurements over short
periods of time to try and track that
recovery the thinking behind the
fungi specifically is that the fungal
bodies are these
networks of mycelium of hyphae
and so the tillage breaks them up and
parts will not
recover very super quickly as opposed to
bacteria which are so tiny
that um that their bodies are not going
to get broken up by tillage
but i would say that from what i'm
seeing that
fungi diversity actually does recover
decently well after
one one tillage event
that's about all i have for if maybe if
you could expand on that a little bit
more
teal um talking more generally about
you know as you get an estimate of the
fungal
biomass how does like
general fungal activity differ from amf
specifically in its function in
the soil um amf
being a symbiont that we know helps with
phosphorus acquisition water acquisition
but more of the function of fungal and
the fungal activity more
broadly in the the soil community
yeah so the mycorrhizal fungal species
those are dependent on the plant for
their carbon so that's the main
difference is that the fungi in the soil
they have a different metabolism and
that they get carbon from breaking down
organic matter some type of organic
matter
just like a lot of the bacteria do
and so the symbiont you can
measure you know actually something
that's interesting is mycorrhizal fungi
our dna is i the techniques i use are
these dna sequencing techniques to get a
snapshot of
everybody in the community and those are
actually biased against
the mycorrhizal fungi so i can i do not
feel
comfortable looking at my data set and
saying
what how mycorrhizae you're doing that
is the case where you
probably want to go look at the roots
themselves
and do it that way which is not
easy you know it that is a pretty hard
method to
do well but just thinking broadly
the fungi i think of fungi the free
living fungi in the soil similarly to
what i do is bacteria they're doing a
lot of the similar
decomposition functions and
are competing with bacteria and plants
for some of those nutrients
thanks teal and this question maybe it
relates
and this could go to any of you with
respect to enhancing
soil aggregation through practices but
the question relates to armoring the
soil against extreme rainfall events
obviously more perennials fare better
but what else can we do differently
in grain systems no takers on that
well okay so just collecting my thoughts
here but i'm happy yeah if anyone else
wants to chime in too but
i think see this just gives me an
opportunity to delve into some
soil science really deep discussion so
the idea of how
water is held into soils is driven by
the texture of the soil right we all
know that right sandier soils
don't hold on to as much but also about
the idea of the aggregation
and the soil aggregates so soil soil
that has less disturbance over time is
going to be able to build more
aggregates and then um and then be able
to hold on to water
um between aggregates you know if you
have these stable aggregates it's going
to create a better environment so
so anything you can do um
you know in grain systems so there's the
trick to building aggregates is reduce
disturbance but we also need to
um bring in more organic matter as well
to help
basically be the uh you know to build
organic matter
let me phrase i'm going to rephrase it
the idea of building more organic matter
that's going to be stable and and stay
in your soils the idea of
you're adding carbon to your soil but
you're keeping it there in that stable
aggregate form so
generally speaking building soil organic
matter connects to that process
so then in grain systems we've got to
figure out a way to
get more organic matter inputs
into our grain systems right so dairy
systems
have a little bit of a leg up more root
biomass from
perennials we do have manure inputs
maybe more opportunities for cover crop
use
if it's if it's corn and soybean focused
don't we lose a little bit of our
ability there so um if we have some
small grains and rotation that gives us
some
um that gives us more opportunities to
get cover crops so it's about thinking
about your overall system and all their
their crops they have a rotation how can
you are there places where you can
add carbon into your soil through manure
or cover crops really based on your
cropping system
it is a great it is a big challenge for
us in in our organic grain systems
and that's a great segue for this next
question
which i think is a really good question
to answer in the next 10 minutes or at
least give some perspective
which you just mentioned they're matt
intensifying cover crops and adding
biomass to the soil
but generally from this work that
miranda
teal described if you had to distill
down
some suggestions of how this work
might help inform farmers to make
decisions with respect to enhancing
their soil health and
their soil biological soil health what
would be some practice
recommendations that you might make
uh sir can you repeat that
so from this work if you were going to
advise farmers what changes and
practices that they might
implement on their farms to enhance soil
health and soil biology
what would you recommend and you had
mentioned intensifying cover crops and
adding biomass into the soil but
suggestions like that
well the the joke i like to make is the
best way to increase your soil health is
to start a dairy
all right so um because there you're
gonna have opportunities to use your
perennials and
and manures um i i i don't know if i
have a good
answer to that question aaron i think
that we have these
big shifts you know in inherent soil
health among
soil types for like a better term
and we have these shifts between
basically farm operations green annual
grain based operations versus
uh perhaps animal agriculture-based
systems that have some level of
perenniality to them
um that's not that's not a very good
answer
the otherwise it everything then
devolves into really i think
i think all of the work that we've
presented today does support
these the general push of of reducing
uh reducing soil disturbance and keeping
the soil covered and
increasing the carbon inputs into soil
so
what does that look like i i don't know
if there's a
i don't have a general record i don't
have a general recommendation for that
you know usually and i would probably
guess the same thing for miranda and
teal and even you right when you
thinking about different farm operations
and chatting with different people
everyone has a slightly different
uh approach to management so figuring
out how it works but
working within those processes
working within those i don't know uh
principles yeah so
this is not too much different from the
side five sole health principles right
so keeping the soil covered adding
maximizing carbon additions back into
the soil and
reducing soil disturbance you know and i
was
i was yes and so and i was always uh not
skeptical but because those we
generally think that's true it's just
like how are they you know these are
general things
how true are they and i guess most of
this work is really kind of cycle back
to like yes
they're they are directionally correct
they do they
they they're they're uh those are the
those are the principles and
um the the work that that then you know
teal's getting into is like
all those the beneficials and the more
detailed work that's really the future
of how does how to specifically manage
for some specific things
i agree with matt about those general
principles i didn't highlight
um in the management practices i showed
but in our field survey
we did see like we looked at the number
of passes from fall to spring
and then um there was a relationship a
very very weak relationship again
because there's so much noise but
the less tillage you had the less
tillage passes you had the higher
your soil protein values were so again
it's like
it's really hard to measure these things
but we kind of have this like
you know common sense idea of like what
to do
but it's like how do you implement that
within your particular operation right
like you have your own ways
yeah and so there's a lot of questions
about manure um
so maybe and that i know you've done a
lot of work on this on the conventional
side of things as well but questions
about
how liquid manure
applications might differ from
um other manure
via grazing or bedding pack perhaps
and how if heavy manure could actually
decrease soil health particularly
perhaps if that was anaerobic
liquid manure
well i'm and uh teal miranda i don't
want to
uh if you have any thoughts please uh i
will so here's my thoughts on this and
that's
it's about the carbon input so we when
we apply liquid dairy manure we're not
applying a lot of carbon
as much obviously as when we're applying
solid manure
so it really if we could ever like
balance out that carbon they're equal
but generally speaking
liquid dairy manure it's everything's
been worked over more it's more
available
it stimulus get that quick stimulation
um
but the long-term you know there's still
there's some evidence even with
long-term use of
of the slow building so generally
speaking we tend to think about the
composted manure the solid manures tend
to have
um maybe a bigger benefit in terms of
uh maybe long-term soil health building
but it might just simply be based on the
fact that we're adding more carbon to
the soil with those
manures so um and it's a slower they
tend to break down a little bit
a little bit slower compared to liquid
dairy manure uh in terms of making the
soil go anaerobic i mean you would have
to apply
quite a bit and pack it down pretty
tight um
um perhaps uh person asked the question
as a specific
yeah i think um and i don't know if this
came up in any of the literature
review for this work um and maybe this
is the way i'm
interpreting it is maybe just the suite
of microbes that are in an anaerobic
dairy manure
versus the microbes that may
be part of a
other manure management
and maybe this goes back to the
mechanism of why manure benefits it's
more of the carbon editions than the
the microbes being applied to the soil
directly but is there
a difference there as well
there's a question related to ph too how
ph
might drive soil communities
yeah i have done quite a bit of
literature review on
manure effects on microbial communities
and soil health and it is one that's
really interesting it's like
adding manure is a great resources to
have to get carbon
more carbon on your field to feed the
microbes to build
soil organic matter that does seem to be
great what's interesting
is that in different long-term studies
that are specifically interested in
testing the effects of manure
we see different microbial species
or taxa dominate in these different
systems that
are probably more about the soil type
and the uk experiment versus the wix
experiment we did but that is one thing
that
is is coming out of these data is that
you have
even at the the largest scale that we
can look at the phyla level
there are pretty big differences in who
is dominating those communities
so we have a lot of work to do if we're
going to understand
um which of those are decomposers of
which types of materials
and can is that even is knowing that
information going to get us
a little bit further in management
recommendations
if it is it's probably going to be small
and there is a clarification to that too
which is really helpful in that this is
actually related to a question that came
up
i know that you were answering earlier
this week on a different topic but
whether that manure could potentially
bring in too much nitrogen that would
actually
more rapidly cycle c so too much n in
the manure burning up the carbon
um
i i i need to uh think about this for a
second so
i only have a long complicated answer
for that because so
in general i understand the point right
if we if we add a lot of nitrogen to
soil
we stimulate the microbial activity the
microbes then
uh stop becoming nitrogen limited
and then can perform more tasks by
decomposing more organic matter
so the so the so the trade-off in our
agricultural systems
is we're also so we're applying the the
nitrogen
and it and it's feeding the microbes it
also uh can lead to feeding the plant so
as long as we're
getting still a benefit in terms of more
like in a corn system if you're in if
you're able to increase yields with your
input with your nitrogen input
so you are still returning more carbon
you could
it could have a net neutral effect right
so the the trouble so but the but the
overall point is interesting right if
we're adding nitrogen without carbon
um there's a negative effect but
sometimes we can get that carbon
through that plant process um and that's
what we've noticed in in some systems
uh as long as we're civil to maintain
that now the the you know i'm
complimenting you know manure quite a
bit here in terms of its benefit on the
carbon side but obviously
i want to acknowledge there are some
obviously limitations in terms of
nitrogen and phosphorus and their
effects on the environment with manure
that we need to manage so i would be
more concerned about
managing for those principles first i
think we're applying within the realm of
of proper nutrient needs i think then
that's
beneficial going beyond that uh is
probably
where bad things happen all around
yeah that's an interesting and
interesting question
um there's a question related to if if
anyone is um uh
any comments on um
uh ryze's ryze's why can't i
say that word rise of
and how that just i don't i know that
wasn't tested within the scope of this
research but any comments in
general
[Music]
all right my work hasn't been um
at that level of function of
the metabolisms of different microbes so
i'm not
i'm not super familiar on how management
or anything would affect rhizophy
or eating of roof
all right um so we're at the top of the
hour um
thank you all for a really
informative presentation on on so many
different aspects of
soil biology and soil health and
particularly as it relates to
organic grain and dairy systems
um so with that
um can i make my final oh yeah of course
matt
just as we wrap this up just you know as
you think about those three circles
and why soil biology hasn't been
incorporated i i hopefully this
you know it's it's it's a huge challenge
we've done a lot of work
just to you know and our main results
are now we feel really comfortable
that you know this is the this is the
correct direction
and then but we still need more work by
miranda and teal right to get at those
very specific things and that's going to
be the grand challenge for a lot of soil
science research but it's not going to
come
quickly but we appreciate everyone's
patience
it's an exciting area there's a lot that
we still
have to learn but it's exciting to see
this this research coming out and
appreciate the efforts of all of you
[Music]
you